good morning guys
today has already started off as kind of
a stressful day it is barely nine but
we've been up since six which is not
abnormal five five actually which is
abnormal
um
bart
it looks like you're about to crash no
i'm not even okay all right
um and today we had to take taika to a
pediatrician out here in vegas it's the
first one that he's been to out here so
we were all kind of testing it out um
because he needed to get his regular
vaccines for school i remember we when
we all had to get that like chicken pox
measles all that stuff uh so he's due
for it
so we had to take him he got three shots
today
monkey how you feeling
sad
we were doing so good
all right i get it i hated the doctor i
could i recall the time that a nurse i
don't remember how old i was but a nurse
was like okay here's a little butterfly
and i was expecting it to feel like a
butterfly looks because i had never felt
the butterflies so i just expected it to
look i mean to feel
light and nice and soft and then it's
it stung me because this [ __ ] pricked
me in the arm and i remember dogging her
and going it did not feel like a
butterfly at all of course with tear my
eyes
so
yeah trying to navigate that while
trying to keep him calm while trying to
keep him
because he's still warming around yeah
because he's he's so curious too he
wants to look but then the nurse is like
don't let him look and i'm like oh crap
what do i do but we got it done
and now we're on our way to california
because um it's thanksgiving week for us
and i mean we have no family out here so
we're going out to see family and uh
yeah spend the thanksgiving week with
them taika has no school anymore
um or at least for this week
so yeah excited to get out there spend
some time with friends and family gonna
see everyone we're gonna see joe we're
gonna see david we're gonna see all the
friends back in california i couldn't be
more excited um
glad the stress i hope this is like the
most stressful part of the day
i hope nothing else
beats this because it was pretty it was
pretty gnarly for everyone did you feel
stressed
um
oh getting ready to go to california uh
just today
a little bit just because there's so
many moving parts like usually when i go
on my trips to la it's like a two or
three day trip right or so i don't have
to pack that much so packing for five
seven days for us to end the third
little dude oh did you pack did you pack
for this
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait okay i could have sworn you
just because we don't have that much
battery life on this camera
no this is the first clip no no we can't
be wasting on bs it's the first clip and
i washed i washed and folded like
three weeks of laundry camera works do
you know how kind of looks
um i packed my stuff and the battery
life on the bs all right dude all right
so what is all the stuff you did so like
well squats for one floor press okay
dumbbell rubber that's like girls are
squatting what you squat so
what i mean are you trying to say it was
a heavy load what are you talking
there's no girls that can squat
315 pounds a world record holder
there's women pulling 600 deadlifts dude
hey
good for them
yeah well all right so you calling your
load heavy or moderate or what do we
talk about i'm calling it badass okay
all right so yeah you did all that today
poor guy
that's why i was stressed out
do you think papa is a poor guy you're
the one that got the three shots in the
arm are you sad for papa
or sat for yourself
yeah you hear that dude i'm sad for him
hey that's part of my best part of my
thing all right anyway
well yeah i hope today i hope that was a
the most stressful part of today
honestly i hope it's the most stressful
part of the week
but we'll see a week's a long time from
now
okay so first stop getting gas and this
gas station holy crap it's
blown out sorry y'all there we go this
one has a mcdonald's so papa got the
family's mcdonald's what'd you get baby
i got uh
my favorite mcgriddle
yeah gotta get up the hash brown and
then these guys my sausage burritos
these whole things
i mean this is for is that a coffee or
soda
no it's not i'm just kidding this is for
uh black coffee
and then tyke and i went to
the liquor store there that's attached
to the mcdonald's that's attached to the
gas station picked up something kind of
healthy uh beef jerky water
baked flamin hot cheetos
and then this is when it goes downhill
and then oh my god
how about i mean tyka already had
breakfast so he's eating a nutritious
holy crap not all of it okay
i gotta take that away from him it's
gonna be nuts he knows the whole thing's
gonna be gone i know i gotta take it
away from him
[Music]
my dad never kissed me i honestly think
my dad has never kissed me in my life i
mean look at you
i barely want to kiss you what do you
mean you've kissed my man parts before
no i haven't yeah you did bro you always
kiss my man parts
you love doing that well that your face
isn't on the man part i like the man
part
hey stop sticking your hands down
hit it hey get it let's go inside
monkey cheetah
here
let's go
all right so we just finished lunch and
what did you just say or dinner i should
say what skinny is my dad has never
kissed me in my life and so far i've
witnessed my dad kissed taika at least
three times
look at him
it's super cuny being back in the 626 a
part of it is cuny because i mean we're
back in the 66 and we've eaten here so
many damn times if you are from the 66
you know that this is a [ __ ] staple
uh it's been here for decades
and if you haven't eaten here you should
just eat here it's not like the best but
it's definitely a 626 staple and you
haven't been to the 626 if you just
didn't experience bacali the sad part
about it is that like
we're still here you know and like i
mean the whole world's going through it
so i understand but it's just sad when
like these businesses these mom and pops
you know they're just getting so
affected
by this thing it was so empty and it was
really heartbreaking because i want
these places to
survive so that's just the sad part but
in other news look at this [ __ ] sky
you guys
and this does not do it any justice
maybe that does a little bit of justice
it's so damn pretty
wait
okay go what did you see
me the picture i said no
no
that
and then there's another one there's
another one
do you know what that is
it's a cigarette and it's yucky
and it's stinky no smoking
you did that
i don't know
there you go oh
and
so we are now in my mom's house and the
first thing bart decides to do the drunk
guy over here
look at this
look at
this was a family heirloom this ran in
my dad's family honestly for like 40
years you guys were poor then that came
over from spain
like i said before for 40 years
let's get one from spain
from spain spain street and boyle
heights
wow what a hater dude i don't go to your
parents house breaking [ __ ]
that's messed up watch what's what's
going on what is this who did that
what is that look at that who did that
is that your spanish tradition too
exactly
ice cream
[Music]
butt butt
that's all i can see
got you
how ridiculous this guy is i'm gonna set
the camera down and i'm just gonna try
to like casually record him okay
[Music]
come on dude
[Music]
did
i'm so sorry mom
[Music]
so i messed up
i ordered
i ordered a quesadilla
not knowing it was gonna be so small and
i couldn't even show you guys because i
ate it already but it was tiny
and then
gio's mom felt bad for me so she's like
want me to make you one and now she's
making a legit one
that's even bigger than the one that
came
thanks maya the best
churches
sixty dollars
what's the special ingredient that goes
in here
[Music]
you turn that off and i'll tell you okay
what's in here i think that's that's
when you're cooking you put your
oil in there oh okay
but i don't cook soda okay thanks maya
you're the best
oh
those special quesadillas huh your mom
put the secret
last ingredient there there's some good
stuff look at that oh
those are the ones that come in the
jalapeno thing too
hmm go
i see why you want to put the carrots in
there
it's the jalapeno carrots
thanks mom you're the best
hey that's my mom
this guy's so tired
he knocked out
well just hanging out with mama patina
my favorite
is your favorite when he's sleeping
because he's not a maniac
a big kitty petunia
i'm gonna carry him and put him in bed
he gets to sleep with grandma tonight
which is his favorite super favorite it
is little tortoise
good night good night see you tomorrow